Hale welcome back to another episode of
big mug yay oh let's sound off who's
here starting with me it's Gina hi it's
Bose okay
sounding off this is Gina today we got
TIFF we got Jess we got both and we have
the beautiful the one and only with the
perfect makeup and the jewelry line
[Applause]
coming in the left corner girl these are
coming back hi guys thank you so much
for having me I'm so excited to be here
with you guys our first virtual guest
and it had to be you girl ahead of
course we love us some Stacie go Stacie
what's your Quarantine life been like
we've been talking about ours a lot over
the past few weeks fill us in girl so
basically I'm like the only person in my
family that has been staying home
because all my family they're like
essential workers so when everything
started breaking down like my anxiety
was through the [ __ ] roof or I wasn't
leaving my room and I was like nobody
touching me like don't talk to me don't
even look at me you know like I would
come out of my room and I would like
this infect everything and stuff but I
think like as time has gone by like I've
kind of relaxed into it a little bit and
I work from home like all of you guys so
I I really been enjoying it now like
I've been doing helot random ass [ __ ]
projects like painting and tie-dyeing
and doing a bunch of different things um
on yeah so I'm just gonna set on the
inside like I don't really mind it as
much as I did in the beginning in the
beginning was [ __ ] chaotic but now
I'm bigger children have you been
quarantine by yourself or you have
someone with you and I have your Buffy
so I have my final yeah my sister lives
with me my sister my lips together and
then my boyfriend occasionally comes
over
I want to know how that's going you
actually have someone with you like well
you can kind of still hook up during
quarantine I'm a little bit jealous not
gonna lie I feel like hooking up is so
different though when you're in no like
long-term relationship like that's not
hooking up bro yeah like you know what
tell me about it you know what sucks
right now I was talking to one of our
mutual friends actually he started
dating someone new and like during like
this new honeymoon phase they've only
gone on like two dates and now it's just
her over at his house all the time like
the whole honeymoon dating phase is
completely skipped and they're like
sample living together now they're like
what do we do no quick way to figure out
if it works or not do you guys think
that's a good thing or a bad thing like
you could you come in you kind of like a
guy and then suddenly you have to like
stick it out for a month and see if it
works like is that could that work too
much I think it's too much I want to go
on dates I want to be wined and dined
and then like just come over to your
house like once a week or something I
guess that depends what kind personality
you have both cuz I think for me
personally I think I would like that
like I would like being holed up with
someone and really seeing their true
colors yeah am i making my making up my
mind yeah cuz also like I just like I
just want to know like this is gonna
work or not like you know do we want to
waste time on eight dates if we can just
knock it out or no money strange like
married couple lifestyle and see if you
want it or not a guy hey bro my dude and
I we've been together for two or three
years and we still haven't tried that
yet so like I want to know oh yeah you
you should know by now you guys need
important team together for a couple
weeks
yeah time boat huh have you seen her
time it's been rough girl we see each
other I basically I I'll quarantine for
two weeks straight and then see him
because his parents are autoimmune
compromise so like bro like straight up
like this is gonna sound harsh but like
if I end up killing his parents we're
gonna break up and I do not handle that
I think I would be are gonna break up
but also he's gonna murder you probably
literally like
so bad so I'm very very strict with my
quarantine and yeah and then I go see
him and we're separate and it's amazing
person came over to your house and just
stayed with you the whole time dude
good point it's been so long it feels it
feels like empty cuz I would see him
every single week it almost even though
we were only seeing each other on the
weekends it really truly did almost feel
like he lived with me because I work
during the daytime and then I'm kind of
free at night and just now since I'm
always home I like cannot believe he
hasn't been here in like a month and
some change and it kind of sucks do you
live by yourself me yeah I would be
totally alone the only one that hasn't
been to your house yet feels like
everyone's just invited to my house
already
yeah it's been kind of rough because I'm
like I'm dating a guy who loves worked
out and it's such a pain in the ass
because like wait is that a picture of
the guy that is biting that's hey yeah
and like it's really hard for us because
sometimes we can see arguments because
he just wants to work out all day and
I'm like oh my god Michael like I'm just
tired you know but you know I figured I
should get I should show you guys what
he looks like because you guys never see
my boy find or poop right in he's fine
yeah like Michael why don't you work out
by throwing me into that wall how about
like that's all I want
but it's so it's been really hard on us
because like it takes me a while to get
used to him and just walking around
shirtless all the time and like I can't
focus we're at work I know it's really
hard
I'm trying corentin´s been really rough
for me I know what though I've
definitely been a little thirstier than
usual I think everyone has cuz everyone
is either a lacking dick or having too
much digging then we got pregnant
tonight like they're gonna give birth in
nine months birthday during this whole
thing is so it was my birthday on April
5th and [ __ ] I was stressing because
you know how like it went
you break the I don't know if I'm the
only one but you know how you got like
extra set for no reason mm-hmm and like
yeah I don't know why but literally like
I was just like oh my god like freaking
out cuz I was like everybody's gonna
touch me and everybody's gonna want to
give me a hug and everybody's gonna be
happy with me you know and so latina her
her fine ass man right there Wow
now she's licking his a boobie for the
you audio listeners you need to watch
this I haven't seen the movie yet so
when that came up I thought he was
wearing a sweater textured Kilimanjaro
Gina keeps stealing the show with her
ridiculousness
anyway so anyway I was like hella [ __ ]
stressed out like I just was freaky now
but then the day after when I was
matching a birthday my sister actually
surprised me was like my mom and my
brother and my mom never takes a day off
from work so she ended up taking the day
off of work for me and I was like so
[ __ ] happy like I've been stressing so
much other day I was like you know what
I'm just going to get [ __ ] up and I'm
gonna take the day off or worry like
today I'm not gonna worry and then
tomorrow worried again and that's
basically how I was spent I was spent to
here drinking and we had which was oh
really yeah
oh wait what is that I had that I know
what it's spelled marina
it's like cow meat I think it's nice try
to get shredded but it's like it's in
its juice you know being Sonic my
favorite movies hey you can he was gonna
yeah or by itself or like in kinda like
sooo spoon I'm craving it hungry now
should know but boy we ended up dude my
birthday and I'm just [ __ ] glad it's
over because it was so like too much
pressure like everybody was capping on
this Aires because we were the first
ones to have a freaking supporting team
you know yeah everybody was like oh you
handsome and man like once it was over
I'm like okay great
I feel great now like I don't care now
however you know 29
okay I know and we have like a topic for
this week but I got a question for you
guys what's the worst habit that you've
picked up during quarantine I decided to
see how long I can grow up my toenails
my leg hair is definitely reaching a
maximum length
oh my god I was like that but then I was
like the other day I woke up and I was
like you don't [ __ ] this I'm shaving my
legs I don't wanna feel like [ __ ]
because it is now is the time where I'm
not gonna see anyone and I can just do
whatever [ __ ] bodily experiments I
want to do right let me find out how
much I could be yeah I just want to see
like I want to see how long and grow out
my toenails and I've been three of them
boys still don't strong it was good
three of them up now we need to see
share the toenails with us girl
no one will pay for this [ __ ] I said if
you guys want to buy my toenail clippers
out there I'll put them out for my only
fans or something TIFF what about you
what's your worst habit me I have been
waking or okay so this week has been the
exception because I have been a good
girl but waking up early but I'm always
like this entire quarantine I've been
going to sleep like a three and waking
up at like noon sometimes like I'll be
in bed for like a couple hours and I'll
get out and then like eat my like three
or four pm like today I actually I
wasn't good and it's I haven't eaten
it's already 5:30 but my presence those
are my bad habits dude yeah that's what
I was gonna do my worst
thank you you're on the Jeana schedule
hello we are sister but the Gina
schedule is six it's 6 a.m. the sleep
schedule is 6 a.m. until 4 p.m. and do a
nice exemptions for us the other day I
was I was on voice or I was on June with
a few of these girls and they saw me
working out do
Yoga they're like what the yeah this is
a new Jeana it was happening I think
whatever yoga and then she had like a
weight too and I'm like who is Jeana
yeah can you do that
it's weird because it takes a [ __ ]
pandemic for me to be like you know I
kind of want to die with the banging
body you say see anybody uh anybody
habits I think relatable to you guys is
just the fact that like at some point I
went to sleep like at 5:00 in the
morning and I was like what the [ __ ]
and I just person don't like waking up
later because I feel like I missed my
whole day but most so there's like
nothing to do so there's one of my
videos and somebody commented it was
like the concept of time is like fake
right now like yeah we know so it
doesn't really matter if you sleep like
at 5:00 in the morning and then wake up
at whatever time like I just I'm
allowing myself to just do whatever the
[ __ ] I want to do you know because
otherwise like it's just too stressing
like there's no rules right now yeah I
saw something on Twitter the other day
that made me feel a lot better cuz have
you guys felt really like just kind of
lazy or unproductive but you're still
like actually getting [ __ ] done mm-hmm
you just like feel like it it said it
said you can't compare your productivity
to did like today to what it was two
months ago because that world doesn't
exist right now so it's just not fair to
you and that kind of just let me like
breathe a little bit better cuz I'm
thinking about like how you know
everyone's like moving and shaking two
months ago and now I feel like such a
lazy piece of [ __ ] but like we're
supposed we should enjoy this as much as
we could use our one chance to be pieces
of [ __ ] and no one can say a thing about
it
yes I'm fun that I've read I saw and
read it I have it actually says an
abnormal reaction to an abnormal
situation is normal behavior
so like this all of this is really
abnormal and even like me working out is
abnormal behavior in this abnormal
situation
I feel like a lot of people have been
really blue like yesterday I was feeling
just [ __ ] dreadful like I did not feel
good at all
Gina I think like you sleeping at 6:00
and waking up at 4:00 p.m. like there's
a little bit with your circadian rhythm
that I'm concerned about slightly I know
you wanna know something [ __ ] up I've
been getting up pretty goddamn early
which is weird is that
Gina's like you know even working seven
there's a mysterious light in the sky oh
I want to know specifically because like
Casey and see if you got you guys live
together bosey boughs you're all by
yourself just you can by yourself also
literally by myself you yeah I've had
boyfriends and whatever a husband you're
weak you got two dogs they love you
though I got me and a bunch of post
mates back and then Stacy even seen you
boyfriend how have you guys's
relationships been affected by this
whole porn scene thing because I see so
many memes of like I'm gonna kill my
husband I can't [ __ ] stand head my
wife at home when he breathes I want to
punch him in the face so how's it been
for you guys you can take it safe travel
first um
so personally I can say I really like to
be by myself like I but I only like it
when I have the option to be so for
example like if I was in a situation
like no shame no tjs but like if I was
like in jazz shoes I would be having a
really hard emotional time because I
feel like whether we like it or not
having someone there to text or to be
like dude I feel like [ __ ] right now or
whatever the case may be like that must
be so tough to not have like a backbone
backing up the whatever so in the
beginning my boyfriend has made
decisions regarding his quarantine mean
period that mate like personally I
wouldn't do for example like I don't
know like not that this has happened but
let's just pretend like if you went to
the super super market without a mask
and gloves and like touched his face or
things like that you know
otherwise that behavior you would have
never been able to know you know so just
decisions that I would have made
differently he's made way different than
me so I freaked out on him and I'm like
we need to be more responsible and you
need to be more careful and blah blah
blah and like I tend to like project
into the future a lot and I'm like dude
if we [ __ ] had kids like you wouldn't
be able to come around the kids and
[ __ ] both and I'm just like [ __ ]
you don't have kids like right now I
mean this is the period before you have
kids we were testing his viability as a
husband and a father so I don't know if
you're really that wrong for some the
way you have to see it because that's
the same way I thought about it too but
the way I see it now it's like well he's
not a husband and a father yet so his
actual ease might be different yeah
because I feel like the way that I act
now like yeah like I'm reliable I'm this
I'm that blah blah but once I become a
mother like I will step up whatever my
behavior already is you know what I mean
like if you are already married and had
kids like I wouldn't leave the house at
all I can go to the supermarket on his
own and like with the list or whatever
and come back and I'm glad I don't
[ __ ] have kids right now
um but yeah so like when things like
that would happen I would be like hey
like I need you to wait at least a week
before you come over the house you know
like I don't want to see you because you
know whatever is essential to you might
be different than what's essential to me
and that's fine I respect it but you
have to respect like my anxiety levels
you have to respect my rules you have to
respect the way that I'm choosing to
live through this pandemic you know so
we're getting like a good rhythm now
like he's been here for the past couple
of days and I [ __ ] love him I [ __ ]
do but I love being myself outside the
door like [ __ ] to believe it I don't
know it just makes you wonder like oh my
god cuz he's been here a lot so I'm just
like how do people live together like oh
no why do guys plan on living together
soon right eventually like I love him
and he loves being with men but I just
think that when we have our own place I
want my own
like together but I want like my office
my closet room or my op like my makeup
room or whatever that was like a place
for my own yeah there's gonna be by
myself you know yeah and you know I feel
like you should have like like a like
you this and share a bed but it's got to
be comfortable you know and you know
what would make that bed really
comfortable above the comforter that's
right try my favorite thing in the whole
world how am I not memorize this yet you
know this is a eucalyptus fiber super
soft earth friendly bedding it gives you
the best night's sleep I talk about this
all the time you know when you go to bed
in a hotel it's not the mattress it's
not it's not the mattress it's not the
sheets it's the comforter dog and I
swear to god this comforter gives you a
hotel style experience I'm knocked out
every night drooling stuff I almost said
the S word if you if a eucalyptus fiber
that's breathable cool to the touch and
it gives you the best sleeping
temperature you don't overheat so it's
perfect for the summer their products
are cruelty free and hypoallergenic you
know I like that there's no down
feathers or animal products at all and
it has over 20,000 five-star reviews
that come out to a 4.6 rating the
numbers don't lie y'all and neither do I
that's right [ __ ] comforter with $20
off by visiting Buffy CO and then enter
the code mood once again that's 20% off
of your Buffy comforter all you gotta do
is visit Buffy CO and into the code mu
and a lot of successful couples have
always said that when you share a bed
always have to comforters so you're not
fighting over tonight so get to Buffy
comforters get to well I have one Buffy
and we're pretty good but two would be
better I need another one I need like
three and what's the best way to shop
right now is to shop online
because when you're sucking warranty and
you got nothing to do all you do is shop
and I be shopping so much somebody
please help me I'm spending so much
money but not that much money why
because we have honey we all shop online
a lot especially now but did you know
that you can make online shopping even
better you can with honey honey is a
free
- tool that saves you money honey
automatically finds all the best promo
codes online so all you have to do is go
to your favorite sites like Target Best
Buy Sephora Oh fora mm-hmm shiny basic
makeup
mm-hmm even eBay and when you checkout a
pop or a little box pops up and all you
do is click on it and it says apply
coupons and you wait a few seconds for
it to scan every promo code on the
internet to find you the best ones and
then watch your prices drop I've been
using it lately because like I said I've
been spending a lot of money for no damn
reason not my rooms a mess but I saved a
bunch of money also honey has found over
18 million members over 2 billion that's
the billion dollars in savings not using
honey it's literally passing up free
money it's free to use and installs in
just two clicks plus it's backed by
PayPal see you know you can trust it so
now you can get honey for free at join
honey calm / mood that's join honey calm
/ mood save some money in this
quarantine shelf mule you're welcome
yeah I need to go to Sephora today once
we get off I'm gonna go buy so I need
did all my makeup is expired now just go
so well luckily you don't have to go
anywhere I don't have to go anywhere for
sure but oh yeah everything I've ordered
so far is like please allow 30 days for
shipping because of kovat and I'm like
good days 5 days max is still there I'm
like okay I'm gonna play it safe how are
you in case of doing this porn scene
together and Isaac together - yeah so
Isaac he's he has visited his dad every
two weeks so we have like a weekend off
wait well every two weeks he'll spend a
weekend there so like we're still like
trying to be safe because I'm like his
family is also quarantine because he
lives Isaac's dad lives with his mom so
and there's like kids in the house and
stuff so they were trying to be safe and
so that's been an interesting just
having Isaac here all along and
having him work on homework he's like
I've said before like a million times
he's so responsible so I'll have to be
on him about getting his homework done
it's really weird though because they're
gonna do a virtual Assembly on Thursday
so I'm like I'm like hey I'd like I want
to be there I want it I want to know
that this is gonna be where apparently
they're going to do like a zoom virtual
assembly with like all the like for all
the sixth and seventh graders like
that's interesting my problem with that
is every [ __ ] assembly I went
to in school was pointless like name a
single assembly that we needed so why do
you like that ecologies dude I like that
because I got at a class but like I
don't remember a single poignant totally
boring yeah yeah like I don't remember a
lot instead of eating him there and
being bored rather than being in class
and like eliciting to a lecture so I
love just sorry that's why for this one
I was like I need to see what this is
like like this what do you know look I
remember yeah do you guys know I
remember when I was when I was a kid we
had like an assembly but was like a very
young like sex ed kind of assembly I
think this was like in fifth grade and
they split the boys and the girls to
teach them about you know there was
respective parts and stuff I remember
that one yeah and then I remember the
woman saying like this is a tampon and
you put it in your vagina when you're on
your period and I raised my hand because
I honestly didn't know like what's a
vagina and then chaunce you kind of
listen she goes um the bigger hole and
I'm like the kids around me like that
when I ask the girls around me were
laughing I was like there's like you
know what a [ __ ] vagina is you know
yeah that's the one thing I remember
from like that's a one assembly that I
remember damn well at least now you know
what it is no like you haven't like you
said you haven't seen your boyfriend
wait I tell you my way yeah we didn't
win oh sure that's right sorry it was a
married woman I mean I I kind of
mentioned it before too but so we start
my mornings I was a little bit gone
sorry okay
so I okay so Casey and I we've been used
to this lifestyle of like working
together living together like being at
home most of the week because our jobs
like we only have to go in whenever we
which before this pandemic we would go
into the office once a week or he
actually he would go in like twice a
week because he'd have like a meeting
with the guys like a writing meeting or
whatever but for the majority of the
week we would be together at home so
this is not too different but it has
heightened like a sense of like cabin
fever so we do kind of like nip at each
other a little bit more than we normally
would in the past but it has been great
because we have result our problems more
than we would in the past no we're like
we have no other place to go like we
might as well be like good vibes in this
house since we have nowhere else to be
you know so it has allowed us to resolve
ourself a lot faster our communication
is getting a lot better because we're
able to articulate what it is that
bothered us or whatever the problem is
we're able to to just get through that
quicker so this quarantine for in my
opinion it has helped our relationship a
lot so dude do you guys when you're
working because obviously you both work
on the computer and stuff do you guys
work in different rooms or is literally
like sitting in front of each other like
typing away no you see this right here
where I'm pointing that's my office
right here on the bed I'm here yeah
let's leave it that every single night
oh um so this is my office
and Casey likes to work on a table so he
works
usually at the dining table which is
downstairs but more recently like today
for example he likes to take his laptop
outside in our tiny tiny little patch of
dirt backyard Oh cute he's just chillin
out there and working on it but for the
most part we don't we're not in the same
room when we actually when we work but
we try to spend as much time as we can
when it's not work-related like free
time stuff like well we'll watch Netflix
or whatever or we'll have every meal we
sit together like as long we're just
trying to like spend family time that's
good so you guys have been taking that
time like you guys are forced to deal
with problems with each other now and
that's actually pretty cool you talk
things out because I know couples when
they they have
the opportunity to they kind of xsplit
and go their different ways to kind of
just cool off that's pretty cool true
yeah mm-hmm yeah I think I think my oh
I'm just gonna say I think that couples
that have very poor communication will
be pushed further apart and has the
problems will be amplified and they
can't talk it out but for you guys even
if there was an issue it sounds like
you're speaking the same language which
is a really good indicator for the
future of your relationship - yeah
that's true because I honestly I would
have labeled us as like worst
communicator you can't communicate as
possible in any like history of
relationship whatever yeah yeah that's
good we're making diamonds over there
with all this pressure seriously I was
actually doing good for some people then
what about you Gina right um it's good
like me and a man here you know
sometimes we have some problems
Michael we work it out you know like we
get into arguments and I'm like you know
I need you to make me feel better and he
just lays the pie but you know like my
relationship so if I keep it pretty
private I've been I've been pretty it's
been good it's been good here like I
have no complaints here yeah no fights
at all oh here and there like nips like
we give each other here and there I was
just gonna sign you to go crazy with
Jess look at her and all right he just
needs you to go 14 with her oh and just
corn tea together if you guys are both
yourself
my boyfriend yeah yeah yeah but you know
I actually I
well I'll fly you guys about mine since
I you guys kind of know a little bit of
it but I also need some Stasi advice too
so Stacy I gotta catch you up on this
dude right before quarantine my boy and
I almost broke up like it was it was
totally valid like there was some
repeating behaviors in him and I just
felt like I had given up at this point
and here's the crazy thing so this is
funny I was actually shooting JK news
like the week that like this happened in
two days and like it really came to a
head on a day that I was shooting JK
news girl I was I thought I was so done
and there was a female best friend that
was in the picture okay and just long
story short it was like it was like we
had to break up and girl I thought I
could do it please help me understand
this Stacy I was sitting in the car I
was on lunch at JK and we started
talking about it like very and this is a
little before quarantine we started
talking about it just really getting to
the meat of it and I felt like this
issue wouldn't be worked out so I did it
I was like trying to utter like you know
we have to break up and oh my god I hope
I don't cry talking about this oh okay
dude it was I'm gonna cry it was the
worst pain I've ever experienced in my
life I've never I haven't really I've
been broken up with like one time maybe
but I've usually broken up with guys and
it was when the time was done and this
was a point where I thought I was ready
to walk away but it was like this guy is
so we've been together for two years it
was like he's it's like he's intertwined
in my veins and when I thought we were
gonna break up it literally felt like
somebody was just uprooting all of my
like organs in my veins and everything
out of my body it was like it was a
physical pain and like when and I
literally like screamed when I thought
that it was like over because like I
felt it it felt like I was being stabbed
in the [ __ ] heart like it was insane
and I've never felt that before it Stacy
why did that happen to me but but also
just I'll date you so that was right
before and here we are you see it
would've been yeah what
felt that before but just you know like
at this point I feel like I took every
second with him for granted this man is
like we are one I didn't I it was insane
so like we are on amazing terms at this
point but like a month ago I'm like what
[ __ ] happened to me am i that deep it
so quick question are your parents
together are separated my real parents
are separated but my stepdad has been
with my mom for about 10 or 15 years and
they're great inseparable they're great
I love him do you remember like your
parents like separating or that this
happened when you were sold it or they
don't remember no they were never
together they were like not married they
kind of yeah so okay so I think a lot of
it has to do have you ever been
heartbroken before no is always the
worst one feelings are you describing
like I think for sure I felt them I'm
sure you guys can all relate to those
feelings but dude I swear by this the
first one feels like you're getting run
over and like somebody tie you to the
back of a truck and they're just pulling
you through the dirt yeah and then they
get out of the car and they just start
stabbing me yeah I we we didn't break up
because I could not the emotional pain
turned into a physical pain and I
couldn't handle it I didn't understand
why right well I think just like I've
ever gave me nothing to say like a super
important to say about this is you never
bring up the breaking up part or like
even give it to them like hey I'm
thinking about this because then if you
say I think I'm gonna break up with you
you're like no no no I hurts too much
then they see that you have like
literally a physical dependence on them
and then they're like well I can do
whatever the [ __ ] I want because she's
not gonna break up with me no matter
what I do so I'm like you can like deal
with your own shade go to a therapy
write your own [ __ ] down but don't bring
this up to him until you're either ready
to walk the [ __ ] away or you're like I'm
gonna write this out on maps
lutely dude I don't know how many times
where I felt like I was strong I was
like yeah doing the right thing in my
life and my relationships and then I
tell them and then I can't do it and
then I'm treated like trash no the
[ __ ] day after that it just goes
downhill oh yeah we really see that for
you like it's like you can't even
respect your own word why am I gonna
respect you like you're not gonna leave
me that's true I'm glad they got the
physical yeah go ahead
so my therapist she actually specializes
in where I forgot what she called it
this is weird this weird kind of therapy
but um the whole thing like my therapy
sessions with her she would have me just
say like something painful about my past
or whatever that I'm carrying like my
trauma and she would have me be very
mindful of where in my body I felt any
sort of tension or any sort of like
buildup or anything because she she says
that and also like a car totally he says
there's a lot where your emotions like
emotional pain is like there is a
physical repercussion from it like your
emotions literally feel like you're when
you're stressed for example when you're
stressed you have high blood pressure
you end up heavy like you know heart
attacks or whatever like you're you go
bald you're reading the physical exactly
breathing problems and all that stuff
like emotions are tied to your physical
body like you will have a physical
reaction to whatever emotions you're
having so even when you're angry for
example when you're mad take a second
like wind up next time you're mad take a
second and actually enter the next hour
I'm gonna see not anyone like I'm just
saying like anyone so cuz I did this
after my my therapist told me this and
she was like you really just take a
second you're gonna see your heart is
pounding your your body has a reaction
to that emotion so like your your breath
starts getting more rapid or like your
your your vision starts like shaking
like crazy like oh my god exactly do you
know about the blackout somebody know
like when I get like real angry my
vision starts straight up shaking and I
have to like hold on to something
because I guess so
mad yeah I'm good if you take a second
and actually think about how your vision
is getting shaky and you you analyze it
like you actually note it like you're
you're looking at it from like a
third-person perspective or like oh
that's interesting
my vision is getting shaky or oh my my
heart is pounding so so loudly that I
feel it like outside my chest or
whatever like you actually label how you
were visit your body is reacting as soon
as you start labeling it it's gonna
start dissipating and like that's how
you manage your stress that's cool yeah
yeah I like this topic actually they say
you think of someone who's very um very
in tune with her emotions and like life
experiences and all that stuff like
you've been through it and this you
understand it how do you like I get this
question all the time in my DMS and we
get it in our comments - how do you
personally deal with breakups or like
stress from your relationships
oh my gosh so thank you for long yeah I
love that Stacey Diaz gives us the
therapy we need yeah we're all solving
because I always say man like if I
didn't have to like I would be a
therapist like if it wasn't position is
for every years-long
I would do it but I am really really
really good can I just say Stacey helped
save my marriage my marriage having that
talk with you girl you really helped me
see things in a different perspective
where I was like oh my god yeah this is
so simple or whatever it was right but I
if you need to be a therapist because
you know you're about to get 3im text
messages for me just solving for real
yeah oh geez remember first episode
where I met say CD as I called her mom I
don't know I mean I'm just grateful for
the gift that I'm grateful that people
are willing to open up to me but
definitely if you need therapy um my
videos and what I say is not qualified
as therapy like you guys don't need but
to talk about breakups and to kind of
focus on both
because you said something was it was
really interesting you said that you
were ready to break up with this person
but you didn't because you felt pain I I
will say this um one of the things I
noticed was I didn't realize how much I
loved him I didn't realize how deep it
was because every single other
relationship I had this sounds really
[ __ ] up but I've talked about it
before I almost feel like I dated these
guys that were almost like out of my
league for validation and and it wasn't
intentional it was unconscious and then
it's like once I got that validation we
were able to separate easily and I think
that this is the first time that I am
like truly deeply disturbingly in love
and I thought that I could walk away
since it was so easy before but this is
different
yeah yeah and every relationship will be
different but I think it's not like
worth to know obviously I don't know
what made you come to the conclusion
that you were ready to walk away and
that you were like okay I want to leave
this person or whatever but like if the
only thing that's keeping you there like
let's say these are just examples well
let's say for example he's a piece of
[ __ ] he lies he whatever whatever the
[ __ ] like all that beats if the only
thing that's keeping you there is the
fact that you don't want to feel pain
that's not a good enough reason to state
because pain is inevitable so whether
you want to feel the pain like at once
like kind of like ripping off a band-aid
and just getting it over with
or you want to continuously go through
the process of prolonging the breakup
eventually I believe that what's meant
to happen is gonna happen I don't think
we're gonna break up I was mostly
confused about the the I'd never felt
physical pain like that that's what I
didn't really understand we ended up
part of it was definitely me because I
wasn't when you think that you can walk
away from someone or you don't realize
how deeply you loved them you act a
little bit differently and when I had
that revelation of how much I cared
about him I changed a lot of my habits
too and right now we're literally
stronger than ever
um I just don't I it made me realize a
lot of what I was doing to basically
that that a heart staff yeah who's crazy
eyed Reynold about it so I'm gonna
reflect on it one day and
yeah it's wild but yeah so maybe you
need to look into like your attachment
style so I don't know if we if we any of
us have ever talked about this but
basically you can be attached to a
person in three different ways like
there's people that are anxiously in
touch which means like oh my god does he
love me does he love me like please show
me that you love me like that all the
time there's people that are avoidant
attack which is like there's a problem
that rises up between you and I and I'm
like I'm just gonna break up with you so
maybe it sounds like you're there you
know cuz I'm like that like I'm the type
that's like oh you're not doing things
this way or that way like it's just
easier to walk away yeah what's the
third one
me either but the third one is all we
all want to get to which is confidently
attached which means two people are both
like yeah that's my boyfriend yeah
that's my man now when you start to get
deeper into these you start to
understand yourself like [ __ ] I'm the
template spiderfly like I see a prom and
I'm like peace like I'm out let's get
into Moore's like I'm done with it yeah
that's me too like I I'm so quick to be
like ah [ __ ] this [ __ ] you know whatever
like even sometimes with friendships -
excuse me I'm just like oh it's too hard
[ __ ] it I don't care yeah yeah yeah like
sometimes if you just I don't know like
I feel like that's a really really
common one especially for like us as
women in like our 20s it's like yeah I
feel like that's super I'm the exact
same way too because like well growing
up I didn't have like a like a model
relationship as my parents were divorced
so I was raised on like Disney movies
and like romance and so I'm like oh [ __ ]
I might show up to my house with a
thousand roses to tell me they yeah you
don't learn what conflict resolution is
either so like if we're arguing within
like the first six months I'm like wait
a minute in the movies they don't argue
in the first six months they have a
whole 80s montage about how beautiful
the relationship is they don't argue so
this is not right and then someone like
I used to be like that's whenever we
like the first argument like this is not
the one and then I just want to leave
immediately
yeah dude Jeana I you know I find like a
tip go ahead in case you guys were one
like what kind of attachments all you do
have because it's how I discovered mine
is I went to this website called your
personality net and that's where like I
ended up like you do like this question
there and then it's show you talk about
like your best friend your mom your dad
yeah like I think I think those are the
three oh your spouse your person your
significant other and then you answer
questions about your relationship with
them and then they have this chart and
then they chart it like where you are
like your avoidant your secure your
anxious oh and like and yeah so I found
out that generally I'm a secure person
is just side of my relationship but it
was not that great but now it's good and
also this personality this your
personality net website if you create an
account they'll send you an email and
they'll remind you I think it's six
months every six months for you to
retake this entire survey and then you
get to chart out your personality and
your relationship style attachments and
all this stuff throughout times you have
changed throughout the year so it's
pretty interesting so you like go for
being secure to like completely anxious
and insecure and you're like well maybe
this relationship that's new in the last
six months is not helping me even the
emails that you know they look at your
layer like [ __ ] are you okay Millie
you're like your account has been hacked
yeah we're concerned like oh you can
also put likes
like recent events or whatever like I
even I wrote like in my most recent one
because they ask you like has anyone it
has anyone past you know that you know
or whatever and for me I don't know why
you guys but for me Kobe's death like
affected me so I wrote that like yeah
like I had a I forgot what the Holi
label it but like someone that I've lost
yeah or whatever like Cody
yes I really hit that hard that guy
responds to you [ __ ] meet you you know
what I was gonna say about the movies is
like a camera if I said this or not but
I thought about it before is like in the
movies they show you it how it gets to
that point how he likes wounds her and
all of this and then the movie cuts off
before the real relationship ends we see
the honeymoon phase you're actually I
don't even think we see that we see the
getting been getting the girl phase and
then a real relationship stuff indie
movies that's what yeah focus on summer
something Oh 500 days of summer yeah
that I loved that movie
oh my god because I thought that girl
was like me which is really [ __ ] up
honey are you what do you say I said the
girl have you seen 500 days of summer
you said she was mean no she she
reminded me of me in the sense that she
was just flighty and just like almost
like just not dating people for the
right reasons you know it noticed she
was dating which is what dating is you
get to know people until she found the
one for her you know whatever you like
that's allowed like I know most of us
are like in long-term relationships but
[ __ ] you never know like you hidden you
never know like just like how we're
sitting here like our boyfriends can
potentially meet someone and they're
like hey you know what like this is the
other person that I actually have a
deeper connection with that because
that's true in the day listen at the end
of the day I love your partner that much
you will want the best for them and I
love him anymore I love me and I need
him to stay how about that I used to do
in relationship with me or I kill him
and he has a relationship with Jesus
that's right Gina that's right now I
feel like I do agree with that though
even though it's true he'd be here you
know I did that like I was with Joe for
a long time and like just to really know
like someone is gonna love him better
than I ever could and someone's gonna
love me better than he ever could and
that's just the facts like it uh we
won't we yeah you have to let go
you have to let go of good enough for
perfect yeah before you you know yeah
you can hold tight first of all nothing
truck in space no matter how hard you
hold on to and you know like if it's
meant for you it will get to you if it's
not [ __ ] not even if you [ __ ] cry
throw yourself on the ground and do
whatever you need to do like it's not
gonna say if it's not meant for you you
know what it will stay and will be
reliable for a very long time oh my god
I'd break I have literally owned this
purple mattress since 2015 I freaking
love it I am at risk I have had for a
very long time I absolutely loved it
Jess would you like to tell us more
about it yes so the technology has
improved just about everything phones
cars shopping yet mattresses more or
less have been the same since the
invention of sleep but honestly you guys
looking at y'all have seen the
commercials for purple right like they
got that weird kind of like crate
technology it's super weird I don't know
honeycomb like yeah they call it the
purple grid it's some sort of patented
comfort technology that instantly adapts
to your body's natural shape and sleep
style it's for every body no matter how
you sleep it's designed with over 2,800
open air channels and a naturally
temperature and neutral gel so you'll
never sleep too hot or too cold
dude lately I've been getting so hot
when I sleep so I really wish purple I
mean you guys are sponsoring us can I
please get the mattress to the purple
mattress is soft where you want it firm
where you need it and comfortably cool
all over it's truly a mattress that does
it all you can count on resting easy at
night after night and year after year
purple isn't counting I know it's inside
it for a while purple is so confident in
what they do that every purple mattress
comes with free shipping and returns and
a risk-free 100 night trial so to
experience the next evolution of
go to purple dot-com / big mood and use
promo code big mood for a limited time
you'll get 150 dollars off any purple
mattress order of $1500 or maybe
that's good deal that's perfect I love
this code I know right you had a paypal
price sorry that's purple / big mood
with and use the promo code big mood for
a hundred and fifty dollars off of any
mattress order of $1500 or more and some
terms apply and you know what I do all
my purple mattress best fiends I'll be
besties safe safe to talk about yes I
you guys know how obsessed I am like I
downloading because of this and also
because you would not stop talking about
edifis you really well I literally don't
like listeners do you guys probably
think I'm exaggerating no like off
camera I'm constantly talking about this
game I absolutely love it so what this
game is it's this mobile puzzle game so
I have it on my phone and it's the best
time to pass the time while engaging
your brain and enjoying some really cool
visuals and I freaking love it because
they update their game monthly with new
levels and events so it never gets old
I'm constantly engaged right now I'm in
mushroom Valley on level 432 baby I
never stopped playing this game it's
insane so the other reason why I really
love this this app is because it doesn't
require internet to play which is great
to play anywhere even though nowadays no
one's really going anywhere but once the
once the world reserve resumes and
people will do traveling again this is
literally my favorite travel companion
because I play this on the airplane all
the time so engage your brain with fun
puzzles and collect tons of cute
characters trust me with over 100
million downloads this five-star rated
mobile puzzle game is a must play
download best fiends for free on the
Apple App Store or Google Play
that's friends without the are best
fiends yeah you're welcome nice
in that game for like four hours because
of you after it last time we filmed oh
my god sorry sorry not sorry
I wonder if people should be making
major decisions on like should we get
divorced or should we get married and
things like that during a quarantine
Stacy do you think that like this time
right now is the time to be making major
life decisions in relationships well you
know it's really funny because you know
China was like way ahead of us
throughout this whole pandemic thing so
it came out as a study came out that
actually like hella couples are getting
divorced because now they're being
forced to spend so much time together
which I think just reinforces what I
said earlier how we all need to have our
own individual time I think I mean I've
never been married you know so what the
[ __ ] do I know I don't even live with
anybody so it's kind of weird to make a
decision like a permanent decision based
on a temporary situation but like
imagine if we were here stuck with our
husband or whatever I meet you if that's
all you you know what cases in China's
because domestic violence went up like
crazy yeah so that's kind of that's that
you know with these women we get more
emotional but also I think men they they
get emotional too but sometimes they
don't always know what to do with all of
those feelings
they just feel them and depending on
what type of guy it is it can come out
in different ways I think especially for
the men that were in encourage which is
a majority of like cultural backgrounds
men are not really encouraged to feel
out their emotions so I do have to say
none of which I say like none of the
advice I say count for domestic violence
like if you're in a domestic violence
and i 100% think you should exit that
situation and like there's literally
like none of what i say like oh worked
away or like stay or talked about or
whatever - it does not count like it's
be physically abuse that is definitely
like a whole other ballgame you know
it's only one time yeah yeah
out sister yeah but um yeah I don't know
like it's kind of weird to think about
because again I can't imagine like
thankfully I have a boyfriend who's
super [ __ ] understanding like because
I work from home and he does and by the
time he comes home he's like oh my god
look I want to spend time with you or
whatever if I'm still working like I'll
be like hey maybe like give me two more
hours
you know he's super understanding to be
like okay like I'll we'll hang out like
in two hours you know so that
combination with me also having to make
time for him because I'm such a [ __ ]
workaholic dude like if it wasn't to me
I would just work the whole time like I
enjoy my job I have fun doing it so
having to be like okay like it's 10 p.m.
I'm like I have to cut the computer off
so that I can spend time with him you
know so I think it's just like a
constant compromise from both sides you
know and I don't like I think too
getting married there's a lot of couples
who already had their their wedding
planned for this these times and I've
seen before that like postponed it and
I've seen people who are like we still
got married like we just went by
ourselves and we sang the yeah I don't
know I think it's it's weird ago like
what about though if you meet someone
during quarantine somehow or like you're
getting like you get back with your ex
or something because your coins need
writer like app and you'd like them a
lot you know this is the worst time to
get back with your ex because you're
bored and lonely like oh my god I'm
sorry I'm saying it please don't get
back my ex during quarantine
[Laughter]
way too many months does that yeah yeah
yeah I don't think this is some time to
be getting back with anybody like a
nexus an exploration you know but I
think right now it's the time where
everybody's like bored sad trying to
avoid their emotions this is a time
where everything has been taken away
from us so now you actually have to face
yourself please your emotions face how
you're feeling and so when your phone is
boring like you don't even want to do
anything on the computer anymore this is
the time where you're gonna go back and
look for those connections that you work
with at some point but doesn't send me
that they're gonna work out just because
you're bored you know yeah just go just
go on hinge or whatever and waste all
the time over text messages that are
like oh I'm gonna like me telling all
the people I met during quarantine that
like it's not gonna work out you have
like summer flings is a quarantine fling
yeah they should just whatever guys like
on the apps are they like ready and
willing to meet up or like any of them
just kind of like oh you know I want to
get to know you and looks like wait I
kind of like well I was still kind of
messing around with the app in early
March because like the quarantine stuff
was kind of like I think everyone was
still like oh it's gonna be two weeks or
four weeks max you know so I was just
like I'll still play around with it but
I mean now it's late April and I like I
haven't been on in a while because it's
like some of the guys they were like hey
would you want to meet up still like
meet up somewhere and go for a walk or
something and then I'm kind of like I
don't know like I'm scared to pull
trigger myself your lack of
responsibility turns me off Unsworth I
feel the same as them though like I get
it like I want human connection to like
I want to have sex to like I want to
still be able to date but like I want to
be able to go to a bar or restaurant and
like it just feels weird you know
something I was gonna ask it like just a
hostile relationship going have you
gotten into any arguments is your
vibrator the emotional connection that
you need at these times like do you have
somebody you're into teeny no I mean I
just I I get my emotional connection I
think from the girls right now like I
don't I don't have like a masculine
energy that I can rely on right now but
I think that's a good thing because I
was in a relationship for five years and
then I was kind of dating and I was kind
of like dating a lot for a few months
you know and then so I feel like it's
probably better that I yea break from
masculine energy at least so that I'm
not so clouded by it I think this is
such a good time period to literally
work I know nobody wants to do it but to
work on yourself and spend that time on
yourself and like literally get to know
you
sorry teacher I have a question what
what activities would you recommend for
that like to do that because like for
example when I went to Bora Bora I'm
like okay I really want to work on
myself I want to discover myself or Know
Who I am what do I do
Oceanus on ass dude tip what's a Bora
Bora and gave herself a brand new orgasm
no weirdo myself that way but what is it
like I don't know some activities or
like exercises is what I started doing
again super baby you know I love that
[ __ ] I put Stacy on this app awhile ago
and like I don't know if you thought
they changed the interface and so I
stopped using it for a few months but I
just got back into it it's like a mood
tracker boy it's Hubert why oh you PE
are not sponsored but I love it and like
you it just asks you like two or three
questions each day and you just answer
the questions and it tracks your mood
and so then you can actually look back
on your weeks and see if you're sad four
days in a row physically seeing it
really helps you get out of it and I saw
that one week and one of the biggest
changes I made was I started just
showering every single morning like some
days we skip it because we're you know
working from home and it's [ __ ] fine
but i I've been starting my day every
morning with showering just because I
saw those little blue dots for a couple
days straight like I love that juice
you're using I started making my bed
every morning though that's [ __ ]
weird but you know what
small changes actually helps yeah it's
all good I mean your bed never thought
I'd be that person it's funny cause like
I only do half of my side and all my
case you guys are you read Because okay
so he wakes up earlier than I do so he's
like making his side as I'm sleeping and
then when I wake up I make my side and
it's like a tandem project there that we
yeah what are some exercises they see
that you might recommend so I think to
work on yourself kind of sounds so
cliche cuz everybody says it like love
yours no work on yourself get to know
yourself you know but personally I like
to look at it from like actually facing
your fears kind of way so I'm like yeah
I could stay here until you like write
down your emotions which yeah you should
do that but anytime my therapist would
tell me now it'll be like [ __ ] I don't
want to [ __ ] write down my emotions
ya know so basically the way that I do
it is like allowing to feel my emotions
is the number one theme so for example
if like anxiety comes through you know
like I allow it to sit in instead of
trying to run away from me so just kind
of like personally for me and manifest
on my chest like I feel my heart beating
that's how I feel anxiety so for example
like instead of being like oh my god
what the [ __ ] man she's about like a
hated like I'm so safe why am I always
like this a lot
I'm just like okay like if today it's
gonna be that kind of day that's why I'm
gonna allow it like let's just sit into
a low yeah because trying to fight
anything like it's just avoiding it even
more it's giving it more power you know
so for example if we talk about
heartbreak trying to make yourself feel
shitty about being heartbroken is only
gonna make you feel shittier I supposed
to be like you know what like I'm
heartbroken and I'm allowed to be sad
and I'm allowed to have a rough day I'm
allowed to feel like I'm missing this
person more than ever you know like
things like that especially during these
where quarantine time
hey I'm gonna wake up my dog [ __ ] it
like I woke up on top let's see what
today's gonna bring you know like not
punishing yourself further because
there's already hundreds of people
trying to judge you like why are you
gonna judge yourself when this is the
one thing that's constantly talking to
you you know so one of the things about
getting to know yourselves like spending
time by yourself or by yourself without
a phone without a TV without anything to
distract you it's like sitting in your
pain and being like alright what am i
running away from like what is it that's
constantly trying to get to me that I'm
running so fast from like that the
minute you stop running and you're like
alright [ __ ] what's up like what do you
need you know that's the minute you're
gonna be like oh like this is what I was
afraid of being by myself like there's
nothing wrong with there like I actually
like it you know and then you'll start
picking people from who they actually
are rather than out of loneliness right
that's why it's old dude when I when
this shit's over like I I think right
when I left the relationship I was like
oh I just got to grab up a bunch of
[ __ ] dates and like whatever and then
now I'm like okay we've gone through the
[ __ ] like post breakup like craziness
now it's like I want to pick like a
really right person cuz I know that last
time I kind of didn't so I don't want to
do that again but now I think having to
force myself to spend this time with my
thoughts it's helping and even just
little [ __ ] like I did yoga the other
day and like as I was doing the yoga
something popped up where it was like I
need to apologize to TIFF for something
that I said to her like [ __ ] two
months ago and so I just type said I was
like hey this is super weird but I was
doing yoga and I feel like I need to
apologize for this thing from like back
in it and like but I feel like there's
probably hundreds of little [ __ ] like
that that's like sitting on me weighing
on me and I just can't like find it and
let it out yet but like I feel like in
this moment I can I can pull a lot of
these things out now because I'm not so
distracted by life and I think that's
just gonna help me overall like once
this shit's over you know yeah and once
this is over and you get out of it
you'll pick you're like I've already
been by myself I'm not scared of that
anymore
now I need like from here up like any
man that's from here down I don't need
it out of wanting I'm not gonna
entertain me you know yeah yeah honestly
that was um like kind of going off of
what you just said stacy is kind of the
thing that shifted for me that last
conversation when you were like so if
you if you do this then what's the worst
like so what like you've you've gotten
you have been in worse situations like
why are you so afraid of this one thing
yeah and you telling me that it was like
ah I was like you're right true
beautiful isn't it funny how like it
could be something so small and simple
but you can't be like you you're it's
completely blocked on your mind but
someone else sees so clearly and just
need someone else to tell you and almost
somebody's breaks all the barriers and
you completely understand now yeah I
think that's that's our that's what
Stacy does for us it's not helpful if
like you're willing to receive it you
know yeah see like for me I was on such
a crazy crazy low point for myself like
in the marriage to where I was just like
I need to get out of this like I look
for me like my own experience like
whatever I'm doing in this marriage like
I need it I need a bereavement like put
up a mirror and see like what the hell
am I what's happening and it only got to
that point where I was really receptive
to get the advice that you were able to
give me Stacy so yeah I appreciate it
yeah you gotta be open to it otherwise
it's just gonna go win one ear out the
other
like I've ever wanted to really help a
friend and then like you you'd like you
you know what you want to like say to
them like I feel like Stacy probably
does this all the time but she's just
like oh wait I'm constantly having to
learn when to step in and say something
I want to shut the [ __ ] up yes there's
times where I'm like [ __ ] you've been
[ __ ] dumb but you have to let people
make their own mistakes you know like
you can't like I could say all this and
hundreds of people can be listening and
only the people that are ready to hear
what they need at this moment are gonna
hear it otherwise I didn't program be
like do this which is crazy you know
what I mean both are great you know yeah
so true well I think that's all
we have for today Stacey thank you so
much for joining us as usual you've
always brought big judge wisdom and love
to us and we're still happy to have you
back we hope to have you back again
that's the end of our episode you guys
if you guys liked it please give us a
like and a sub and then we will see you
guys next week be good y'all wash your
hands stay safe